[Music]
this is actually the first giant recipe
i ever did for tasty and what's better
than an ice cream sandwich a giant ice
cream sandwich so for this cookie start
by mixing up your wet ingredients now
some people don't know this but sugar is
a wet ingredient it's because sugar will
melt down into a liquid state some
science for you so you whisk up all of
your wet ingredients and make sure
that's all well incorporated breaking
these steps apart helps to make sure
that you're incorporating everything
fully so you get the smoothest dough you
can without like over beating it once
all the wet is mixed up we're going to
start incorporating the flour so the dry
the baking pattern the salt so now i'm
switching to a spatula to
fold the dry into the wet and this again
will help you
to not over beat the cookie dough
um to give you kind of like a softer
texture
cookie and not a tough cookie i'm a
tough cookie though
now the best part you can throw in the
chocolate chips feel free to add as many
or as little as you like as many
most likely right not as little that'd
be sad so i used two cake pans that were
the same size if you want to do them one
at a time if you only have one cake pan
that's fine but we happen to have two
you can split the cookie dough into each
of those cake pans
and bake it like a giant cookie cake so
once your cookies are off and baking now
we're going to focus on the
middle layer so the ice cream part i
decided to keep it a very classic very
simple chocolate chip vanilla ice cream
sandwich but if you want to switch it up
with your favorite flavors or toppings
or anything you want feel free i
softened up some vanilla ice cream and
threw that in a springform pan lined
with plastic wrap this will just make
your life easier so you're going to
smooth out the ice cream and you're
going to pop that back in the freezer to
set into your disk it's also not a bad
idea to make sure that your cake tins
that you're baking the cookies in are
about the same size as your springform
pan so that you have a uniform
giant cookie ice cream sandwich so once
your ice cream is in the freezer and
once your cookies are baked and cooled
it's important to make sure they're
cooled by the way because if they're
very hot the ice cream will melt more
science for you
now it's all about assembly put your
cookies on your surface you're going to
take out your springform pan release the
sides flip it over and you can peel off
that plastic wrap it should pop out
really easily no mess no fuss then all
you got to do is flip that top right on
top a lot of the cookie ice cream
sandwiches i grew up eating had like
little chocolate chips all over the
outside so because i kind of wanted to
replicate that i decided to cope outside
of the ice cream in these mini chocolate
chips you could also go to in like
anything like any kind of candy chopped
up candy nuts even obviously it's kind
of tricky to pick this up and bite it
like a normal ice cream sandwich but i
cut it
like a piece of a cake which i thought
was kind of clever because then you can
eat it like an ice cream cake giant
foods may seem intimidating but this is
actually really simple to make super fun
super delicious obviously if you want to
see more don't forget to subscribe to my
youtube channel and if you make this
recipe slide into my dms
that was so creepy you should not slide
into my dms after i wink at you
[Music]
so peanut butter cups are one of my
all-time favorite candies so naturally i
wanted to make a giant this recipe is
super super simple so don't be
intimidated by its size just be excited
by its size because it's a giant peanut
butter cup so to start we're gonna melt
down some milk chocolate chocolate is
chocolate it's gonna be delicious
whether or not you pepper it and i
poured that into the bottom of this tart
shell pan so you're just gonna spread
that out nicely with a spoon or spatula
and you want to make sure that you're
going up the sides of the pan you also
want to make sure that you're doing this
pretty evenly because if you have any
like holes or gaps or whatever you just
don't want them
then you're gonna pop that in the
refrigerator to set now we're gonna go
on to the filling so peanut butter cups
obviously don't just have peanut butter
filling fun fact it's kind of like a
fluffier crumblier texture so i'm trying
to emulate that i mixed peanut butter
and i mixed up peanut butter with
powdered sugar and butter do you prefer
chunky or creamy peanut butter
i prefer creamy peanut butter for sure
so once the bottom shell of the
chocolate has cooled and set gonna pour
that peanut butter filling we just made
right onto there and spread that out
nice and evenly then of course we're
gonna top that with some more melted
chocolate and spread that out evenly
[Music]
and then pop it back in the fridge
finally
set so if you want to make this recipe i
highly recommend getting yourself one of
these tart shell pans that pops out just
gonna make your life a lot easier if you
only have like a regular tart pan you
could just still go for it it'll still
be delicious so then like i said you
want this tart shell pan because you can
literally just pop up the bottom and
serve that's literally all you have to
do for this giant peanut butter cup it's
so easy but so delicious
i serve this kind of like
a cake again because
i mean you could just take a big bite
out of it and eat the whole thing but if
you want to share cut a big slice and
ate it like that but again you could
literally just bite out of it take a
bite do you
and if you make this let me know i want
to see it slide into my dms gotta stop
saying that a lot of times when i've
made giant foods they've turned out to
be a giant mess
but this one was really simple
and
obviously delicious if you want to see
me make more giant foods you can always
subscribe to my youtube channel i don't
know how that correlates but you can
[Music]
you either get a pawn or song that's all
i got
[Music]
so this recipe i came up with based on
two things one i wanted to make some
sort of a dome and two i wanted to use
oreos on the outside to make a really
cool visual so i knew this recipe would
naturally be cookies and cream flavored
because i was using the oreos but i
wasn't quite sure which
middle of the thing
i wanted to do could you done a
cheesecake i could have done an ice
cream cake but i decided to go with ice
cream cake because it was kind of new
and also i just really love cookies and
cream ice cream cake that's my favorite
kind of cake it's what i have on my
birthday usually fun fact
so i melted down the cream center in
order to put it back into the ice cream
base that we're gonna make which i might
add is my favorite part of the oreo
fun fact another fun fact this video is
full of fun facts
so the base is made out of more like a
whipped cream and a sweetened connects
milk and it still freezes up and holds
up like an ice cream would but just a
little lighter i would say less like
creamy than an ice cream would be
[Music]
the crushed up cookies will go in there
also
when you're whipping the cream you want
to make sure you get it to the point
where it's thick but don't whip it too
much because then it'll separate so
based on the size of your bowl it might
vary how many cookies you put in the
actual bowl itself but don't worry just
put them in until they line the full
bowl now some people might want to line
their bowl with plastic wrap in order to
get the dome cake out easier but you
actually don't need it it will pop out
on its own the tricky part about this
recipe was when i was testing it
sometimes the cookies would float up and
not stay in place so the batter had to
be thick enough to be able to hold the
cookies down then once you make your ice
cream face you'll dump that right on top
of the cookies and spread it evenly to
cover all the cookies this isn't like a
traditional ice cream this is more like
a frozen mousse kind of thing but it's
super delicious and then super easy just
pop it in the freezer and wait until
it's done you don't want to pull this
out early because you will have a big
mess
and also you just really want to make
sure it's frozen solid so you'll be able
to pop it out of the bowl easily just
flip it over on some sort of a board and
wait until it kind of loosens up and it
should fall right out and then you'll
have this beautiful oreo lined ice cream
cake the most important part of this was
making sure i nailed that beautiful
outside uniform layer and
to say it looked pretty cool
also what's nice is that the cookies
kind of soften up because of the ice
cream so you'll be able to cut into this
pretty easily
[Music]
i think this recipe is great for like a
kid's birthday party because
what kid doesn't like ice cream cake and
also it's so fun looking make it for
your birthday party whether you're three
or 96 i'm sure you'll still love it
[Music]
so
[Music]
you